puisqu'on parle de vaccination une
quinzaine de présidents de départements
socialistes ont écrit il y a quelques
semaines au premier ministre pour leur
dire qu'ils ne voulaient pas verser le
rsa aux personnes qui sont suspendus
justement parce qu'elles ne sont pas
vaccinés vous avez compris cette
démarche vous êtes d'accord avec eux
écoutez il ya eu un débat plus large
c'est à dire que on nous a demandé à
nous de verser le rsa à ceux dont le
salaire était suspendu franchement ça
pose une question de conscience enfin
est-ce que le rsa ça sert à ça est ce
que le rsa c'est la réassurance de ceux
qui n'ont pas voulu de vaccinés dont le
gouvernement a décidé la
de leurs revenus tant qu'ils ne le sont
pas pour ce qui me concerne je ne
verserai pas le rsa à des personnes qui
ont refusé de se vacciner qu'elles
assument leurs responsabilités tout cas
le rsa c'est pas fait pour être une
réassurance le rsa c'est un chemin qui
est fait pour les gens qui perdent leur
emploi qui sont en situation de grande
fragilité et que nous devons accompagner
sur un chemin de vie pour leur permettre
de retrouver la dignité l'emploi c'est à
ça que servent moi je ne verserai pas
assurément et ailleurs donné des
consignes à mes services olivier ferrand
il parle de solidarité nationale lui
vous n'entendez pas cet argument mais
attendez la vraie solidarité nationale
c'est le sauve vacciner
[Musique]